justin trudeau est arrivé à addis abeba
la capitale de l'ethiopie où il amorce
un voyage de 8 jours en afrique
l'objectif de cette visite est de
renforcer les relations économiques et
de tenter d'obtenir le soutien des pays
africains pour décrocher un siège non
permanent au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies justin trudeau participera
au sommet de l'union africaine qui
regroupe les dirigeants des 54 pays du
continent
le premier ministre est notamment
accompagné du président des raptors de
toronto
originaire du nigeria et qui a
d'importantes relations en afrique
canada avec nous pour parler de ce
voyage du premier ministre trudeau en
afrique amina gerba fondatrice pdg du
forum afrique expansion bonsoir vous
êtes également président du conseil
d'administration d'entreprendre ici
votre travail est vraiment de rapprocher
un sur le plan économique le canada et
l'afrique également quelle signification
à ce voyage du premier ministre en
afrique
merci pour cette opportunité écoutez on
essaie de faire ce rapprochement
économique depuis deux décennies et ce
voyage était très attendu en afrique et
représente beaucoup pour nous et pour
les africains qui attendent le canada
depuis très longtemps
certains disent que c'est tard en même
temps que là il va solliciter l'appui
des pays africains pour le siège au
conseil de sécurité
parler de relations commerciales mais
les chinois sont là les ressent la
d'autres sont là est ce que le canada
arrive trop tard moi je pense qu'il
n'est jamais trop tard
dans ce genre de situation chez moi au
cameroun on dit il n'ya rien
d'impossible impossible n'est pas
camerounais
je pense que l'impossible n'est pas
africain tout court donc le fait que le
premier ministre arrive aujourd'hui
qu'il lie s'adresser à l'union africaine
c'est un bon signal et les africains
vont l'écouter
ils ne sont pas dupes et ils vont
l'écouter
oui mais déjà les japonais sont là les
rues sont là les chinois sont très
présents dans un documentaire qu'on va
présenter en fin de semaine
notre collègue azeb wolde et gorgui on
voit que la chine investit énormément en
ethiopie par exemple ça change la
dynamique en afrique que la présence des
chinois
tout le monde est présent aujourd'hui en
afrique les chinois en premier ils sont
très nombreux et sont partout dans tous
les secteurs d'activité ils sont
présents mais les chinois viennent avec
du financement et viennent bâtir
l'afrique et construisent et finance des
projets qui construit donc ça c'est très
apprécié par les africains mais les
africains simple comment gérer les
chinois les gens ont peur de la la la la
vague chinoise en afrique
mais les africains qui quand ils
traitent avec les chinois ils savent ce
qu'ils veulent je prendrai un exemple
très simple qui bâtissent un grand
projet de barrage à l'ombre en gare aux
cadres eux le barrage la constitution
est certifiée est suivi par une société
canadienne qui s'appelle rima cima +
zima plus exact donc ils prennent les
chinois ils prennent l'argent des
chinois bien sûr parce que on veut les
investissements les africains recherche
les investisseurs qui apportent de
l'argent
donc quand tu arrêtes ton argent mais il
accepte cela et prennent des précautions
en l'impliquant d'autres d'autres pays
d'autres expertises pouvait ni contre
espère tease et si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi
ce qui se passe localement mais est-ce
qu'on attend plus du canada est ce qu'on
pense que le canada devrait
jouer un rôle beaucoup plus présents sur
les attend beaucoup et zafy cats ont
énormément du canada parce que les
africains et le canada ils ont quelque
chose beaucoup de choses en commun
on a la langue française et anglaise la
francophonie qu'on vous savez elle est
majoritairement africaine et le fait que
le premier ministre il a parlé à
certains dans leur langue
je pense que c'est un plus pour le
canada mais il faut que le canada vienne
avec un message clair clair je vais dire
aujourd'hui on a le japon qui a organisé
un sommet japon afrique la russie qui a
organisé un sommet russe afrique l'union
européenne qui en a fait un abidjan et
la grande bretagne qui vient d'en faire
un
donc on attend que le canada qu'on fasse
autant
donc nous espérons nous en afrique
expansion que le forum que ce sommet
sera une réalité au canada et on est on
est prêt pour cela
vous êtes prêt j'en doute pas que vous
êtes prêt prête d'ailleurs le canada a
quand même miser un petit peu plus sur
une approche commerciale laissant les
entreprises un peu hâlé et un peu moins
sur la proche consulaires diplomatique
humanitaire
est ce que c'est une erreur je pense pas
que ce soit une erreur parce qu'on
savait la fiq a tout à bâtir et le
canada a une expertise le canada savoir
faire nous depuis une vingtaine d'années
ce que nous observons c'est que les
entreprises canadiennes prennent de plus
en plus de place en afrique neige ont
besoin d'être accompagnés officiellement
et politiquement par leur gouvernement
ce qui n'était pas le cas aujourd'hui le
premier mini ça arrive en afrique
il vient pour prenez justement pour
promouvoir cette relation commerciale
oui les relations diplomatiques et
consulaires sont importantes à une
certaine époque
le canada a fermé beaucoup de consulats
beaucoup d'ambassades en afrique
ça a été très mal perçue par les
dirigeants africains par les décideurs
africains mais ça s'est calmé de ce côté
là et les efforts sont en train d'être
fait justement pour
mais lloret la relation et le bâtir
cette relation surtout au niveau
commercial
est-ce que l'essor l'espoir mais l'essor
africains puis on le voit en ethiopie
par exemple est-ce que c'est fragile que
cet essor économique selon vous à mon
avis non c'est là pour durer
c'est là pour durer pour plusieurs
raisons la première est que les
africains se prennent de plus en plus en
main eux mêmes donc quand on regarde je
le documentaire notamment deuxième on
voit que ce sont les éthiopiens humain
peut ce soir ceux qui sont localement
dans le pays où ceux qui reviennent de
la diaspora
donc on a cet avantage d'avoir les
diasporas très forte
d'ailleurs qui râlent qui renvoie
énormément d'argent dans leur pays et
qui a décidé aujourd'hui de retourner si
j'arrive du ghana ou le président du
ghana a décidé d'accepter tous toutes
les diasporas africaines quelles
qu'elles soient
qu'ils soient de qu'elle soit de retour
au ghana plusieurs pays africains au
fond là l'union africaine a crié un
département qui s'occupe spécialement de
la diaspora
la banque africaine de développement en
a fait autant dans le canada doit
utiliser cette force là qu'est la
diaspora dans son pays pour retourner
prendre la place en afrique et c'est ce
que les africains à temps et avec cette
diaspora et la connaissance qui est là
il n'y a pas de risque que ce soit pour
reculer encore amina gerba merci
beaucoup merci bien